Hassan: There we go.
Hassan: Hello! Welcome to this task. My name is Hassan.
Hassan: I'm a test here. Here. I fable
Hassan: Today i'll be using a dragon, naturally speaking, and so alternative alternative navigation method. on my dell laptop
Hassan: using windows 10.
Hassan: So as you can see here, I'm already logged in to the upscale Qa environment.
Hassan: and my task today is to navigate to the
Hassan: getting started in Web Development Course.
Hassan: which I will complete the first module of.
Hassan: and afterwards I will click on courses
Hassan: to see what percentage of the course I have completed.
Hassan: So throughout that process you may give commands
Hassan: 2 dragons, such as you know, to wake up, record, asleep.
Hassan: or to click on this link or that link.
Hassan: so I just want to give you a heads up.
Hassan: Primarily I will be saying
Hassan: show links as a method of showing clickable links in the module itself. If that does not work.
Hassan: I will try to say the name of the link.
Hassan: If that doesn't work I will
Hassan: divide the screen into a grid.
Hassan: and hopefully h down
Hassan: the area of which I want to click.
Hassan: So let's get started.
Hassan: oh, sorry. I forgot to mention. I will be using Google Chrome
Hassan: with this.
Hassan: Wake up.
Hassan: show links.
Hassan: Oh, click, cancel.
Hassan: mouse, click.
Hassan: pitch down.
Hassan: show links.
Hassan: choose 8
Hassan: page down.
Hassan: show links.
Hassan: choose 9.
Hassan: Go down, 5,
Hassan: go down 5.
Hassan: Okay. So here i'm just reading on
Hassan: what? Exactly I will be doing in this task.
Hassan: Under learning outcomes.
Hassan: So apparently I will learn about
Hassan: visual studio code and get home.
Hassan: which should open in a new tab.
Hassan: Okay, I will continue to go down.
Hassan: wake up.
Hassan: go down 5,
Hassan: go down 5.
Hassan: Go down 5,
Hassan: go down 5
Hassan: show links.
Hassan: choose 10
Hassan: Mouse click.
Hassan: Sorry, Hannah. Just one question for you.
Hassan: Page. Down.
Hassan: Page, down.
Hassan: go up 5
Hassan: go to see.
Hassan: So I will be interacting with this video.
Hassan: so i'm not going to watch all of it. But I will try to interact with the control, such as play. Pause, sending volumes turning on captions.
Hassan: and then, if that works I will be moving on.
Hassan: So let's do that wake up.
Hassan: Miles, click.
Hassan: show lengths.
Hassan: mouse, click.
Hassan: mouse, double click
Hassan: presses. Kate.
Okay.
Hassan: page down.
Hassan: I was click.
Hassan: show links.
Hassan: two's, 12
Hassan: Choose 11
Hassan: like full screen
Hassan: mouse, double click.
Hassan: courtesy.
Hassan: Okay. So as you see there.
Hassan: So the controls actually go away after you. However.
Hassan: after video.
Hassan: and then it's very hard to bring the controls back up
Hassan: by sure, by saying show links.
Hassan: I was able to do it, but I think that was mostly by fluke.
Hassan: I don't the first time I was trying to do it.
Hassan: it was not labeling the controls, and
Hassan: I was unable to activate the captions
Hassan: but the second time apparently it just
Hassan: it was showing the controls again, and I was able to bring it up.
Hassan: so I think
Hassan: the best practice would be to make those controls always there at least
Hassan: and maybe until you full screen the video
Hassan: that way. You can access those things, those controls by voice.
Hassan: And the second thing I would have tried if that did not work is to refresh the page.
Hassan: And you know, I have the when the video now start.
Hassan: In the first place, that way I can
Hassan: set my captions before I actually start.
Hassan: So now that we have the video going in full screen.
Hassan: i'm gonna try to see if
Hassan: I can
Hassan: manipulate the video in this way.
Hassan: Wake up.
Hassan: mouse, click
Hassan: us escape
Hassan: page down.
Hassan: Page. Now.
Hassan: Miles, click
Hassan: for the seat.
Hassan: So another thing I notice is that when you are playing a video in full screen.
Hassan: and you say, press escape to exit
Hassan: full screen. It brings you back up to the top of the page
Hassan: so that might not always be ideal, because your mouse
Hassan: a position might not be hovering over the video
Hassan: in which case it would be hard to
Hassan: navigate the mouse to the video.
Hassan: using voice alone
Hassan: and having a click on the end.
Hassan: So I think
Hassan: if you start
Hassan: full screen over the video, for example.
Hassan: Maybe a more.
Hassan: I guess. Easier way of
Hassan: Entering and examining full screen
Hassan: would be to keep the mouse cursor
Hassan: within the initial location
Hassan: which is over the video in the first.
Hassan: So now that we have done that, I will go down through balm
Hassan: and see if there's anything else I can do.
Hassan: Wake up.
Hassan: go down 5
Hassan: edge down.
Hassan: show links.
Hassan: choose 12.
Hassan: Go to see.
Hassan: Okay, so that's good that it clearly shows you which part of the module you're on.
Hassan: and apparently I have completed the
Hassan: first task in the module, and i'm on to the second one.
Hassan: so again this is.
Hassan: I believe this is a video. But let's go down and see.
Hassan: Wake up.
Hassan: go down 5,
Hassan: go down 5
Hassan: miles, click.
Hassan: show links.
Hassan: choose 18
Hassan: Go up 5
Hassan: Go up 5,
Hassan: Hey, John
Hassan: Mouse double-click
Hassan: bus escaped
Hassan: mouse click.
Hassan: go to it.
Hassan: This video I believe was much easier to control because
Hassan: as seen on this page. There's nothing more than
Hassan: just a video. So there's no
Hassan: you know. Paragraphs are text
Hassan: that one has to navigate to.
Hassan: But one thing I also found is that although the controls disappeared
Hassan: after a couple of seconds
Hassan: numbers, when I said show links
Hassan: stayed in the you know over the controls. So if I saw one number corresponded
Hassan: to the close captioning button.
Hassan: then I would be able to, you know. Just say that number.
Hassan: but for that I thank you. After
Hassan: memorize, basically one number that grows Monday to.
Hassan: So again, I think an easier method might be
Hassan: to keep the controls there for a bit.
Hassan: Besides that, this one, I believe, was
Hassan: an easier activity than the first one.
Hassan: Okay.
Hassan: So I will go on to the next activity. Now
Hassan: wake up.
Hassan: page down.
Hassan: show links.
Hassan: choose 18.
Hassan: Go down 5,
Hassan: go down 5,
Hassan: page down.
Hassan: go to seat.
Hassan: Okay. This one, I think, is also straightforward, because, most of the
Hassan: that. The there's mostly tax on this page.
Hassan: there's no other object to interact with it as a video.
Hassan: there is a link here that clearly says.
Hassan: opens a new tab.
Hassan: so just have the curiosity. Let's try to click that.
Hassan: See what happens.
Hassan: Wake up.
Hassan: show links.
Hassan: choose 10
Hassan: page down.
Hassan: Hey, Job.
Hassan: Go to the first tab.
Hassan: Good. Is it?
Hassan: Okay, so that was simple enough.
Hassan: that
Hassan: open the second tab without interfering with my
Hassan: the open page I have right now.
Hassan: And yeah.
Hassan: So this one. I would give it for Mars, because it was very simple.
Hassan: so let's go on to the next. I to activity. Now
Hassan: wake up.
Hassan: show links.
Hassan: Choose 11,
Hassan: go down 5
Hassan: show links.
Hassan: choose 19
Hassan: choose 15
Hassan: press escaped
Hassan: show links.
Hassan: choose 18
Hassan: miles grid and 9
Hassan: 2,
Hassan: 5,
Hassan: 2
Hassan: start dried up.
Hassan: Mouse, drag up
Hassan: my strike up.
Hassan: Has escaped.
Hassan: Go to sleep.
Hassan: Okay. So here we have. We really on the page again.
Hassan: and I find it much easier now to
Hassan: user controls, but I think it's more simple.
Hassan: before you start the video
Hassan: that we can manipulate. For example, here
Hassan: I was able to adjust the volume, using only voice.
Hassan: and one thing I notice is that
Hassan: if you start a video on the first task there.
Hassan: in the first activity it keeps your preference
Hassan: throughout the whole thing, apparently. And
Hassan: that
Hassan: That's why, when I click on close captioning
Hassan: on this video. It already new
Hassan: that I turn on English close captioning
Hassan: no previous videos. So that's a good name.
Hassan: and that's very good that I can manipulate the volume, using voice
Hassan: And again, i'll just click play
Hassan: just to see if it can be done.
Hassan: And then actually, one thing I haven't done in the previous activities
Hassan: is click on video transcript
Hassan: to see what that's all about.
Hassan: So I will do that. And then, after that
Hassan: I will go to the last task.
Hassan: Wake up.
Hassan: press, escape.
Hassan: show links.
Hassan: choose 17
Hassan: mouse, click.
Hassan: show links.
Hassan: choose 23
Hassan: page down
Hassan: it down
Hassan: show links.
Hassan: choose 10,
Hassan: go down 3
Hassan: show links.
Hassan: choose 14,
Hassan: 4, 3
Hassan: show links.
Hassan: choose 10
Hassan: press escape.
Hassan: show links.
Hassan: choose 14
Hassan: page down.
Hassan: go to sleep.
Hassan: Okay, this is very well done.
Hassan: I have come across images in the past. Where?
Hassan: if there's a slide show, for example.
Hassan: you have to. You can't continuously
Hassan: click back, or you know, Go forward.
Hassan: or you will have to
Hassan: For example, there' be no way to access those controls.
Hassan: using voice or saying show links.
Hassan: They won't even be numbered.
Hassan: So the fact that these are numbered everything seems for accessible
Hassan: here
Hassan: and this is something I really appreciate, because it makes using a web page much easier for me.
Hassan: and I believe our users using my technology would
Hassan: also appreciate this, because again.
Hassan: You don't want to feel stressed out, never getting through something
Hassan: as she, if it's important to your task.
Hassan: so I believe this is very well done.
Hassan: so apparently. Here
Hassan: it seems like, we are done with the first. Much
Hassan: so what I will do now. I I will click on courses
Hassan: and see how much of the course
Hassan: what percentage I have access
Hassan: actually. finished there.
Hassan: Well, let's do that now.
Hassan: and wake up.
Hassan: Show links.
Hassan: Choose to
Hassan: Page. Now
Hassan: go down 5.
Hassan: Good to see.
Hassan: Okay, so that was pretty simple. I was able to navigate everything using Royce.
Hassan: and I can clearly see here that
Hassan: I have done 17 of the scores.
Hassan: so the information one would seek to
Hassan: find out is very easily available.
Hassan: I find. And
Hassan: As for my final thoughts on
Hassan: so I believe everything is
Hassan: perfectly well done.
Hassan: except I think, area for improvements could be
Hassan: having the control 0 permanently.
Hassan: or maybe a in.
Hassan: you know, having them
Hassan: appear in such a way that they don't disappear
Hassan: after a certain amount of seconds, so that
Hassan: people using voice control could easily.
Hassan: you know, turn them on or off at will.
Hassan: and
Hassan: for example, if they want to scrub through the radio.
Hassan: change the volume that could be easily done.
Hassan: As long as the controls don't
Hassan: no disappear too fast
Hassan: which can cause confusion.
Hassan: But besides that I find everything is well done here.
Hassan: Lots of white space, lots of
Hassan: the Transcript. The video transcript was
Hassan: easy to click on and read from there.
Hassan: so even if one does not want to watch the video or
Hassan: it has some other issues with it.
Hassan: They can always go to the Transcript
Hassan: and read everything from there.
Hassan: So again, this sum up, I think.
Hassan: The majority of this was perfectly well done.
Hassan: just area for improvement would be Video.
Hassan: Besides that, I just
Hassan: you know a job very well done again.
Hassan: So
Hassan: yeah.
Hassan: I just want to wrap this up again.
Hassan: Thank you for choosing fable for your needs.
Hassan: Well, you are favorable, but thank you so much.
Hassan: and I hope you have a nice week ahead.
Hassan: Thank you.